(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] When I shop for clothes,
I don't really look at it as
a men's section and a women's section.
I just shop the entire store.
I just look for the things
that look cool on me,
and fall well on me.
(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] I think
in the modeling world,
the reason why they chose
some androgynous-looking men
is because it makes it more
high fashion, more editorial.
An androgynous guy is more striking.
It draws attention from all types of eyes.
(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] When I saw Ruby Rose,
like, I was like, "You're a pretty woman,
"but like, if you were a guy,
"you'd put on a leather jacket
"with the tattoos and everything."
I definitely think that's very sexy.
(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] I identify as a woman,
but I also totally accept
and love my masculine traits,
as much as I love my feminine traits.
(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] Androgyny is
definitely spicing things up.
(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] I've just always
been obsessed with David Bowie.
He's always done that perfectly seamless
feminine to masculine,
masculine to feminine,
and he didn't care what
anyone thought about it.
It was just so perfect and
amazing every time he did it.
(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] As long as my hair is down,
and I'm dressed with clothing
I like, I just feel good.
(upbeat music)
- It's kind of beautiful that
we can all just be ourselves now,
and we can still have jobs
where you don't look like everyone else.
- Someone so unapologetically themselves.
I think that is the most
attractive thing in a person.
(upbeat music)
(squeaking)